I get a burning sensation sometimes where I had radiation after my left breast mastectomy nearly four years ago, what would be the cause of this and how could I prevent it?
Well, nobody knows for sure, but you can speculate where you had radiation, there's cell damage.
This is why I'm not a big fan of radiating soft tissue because you could damage cells that can end up leading to cancer in the future at that spot.
So, you, you know, what can you, so, but also, so there, there could be something like that going on.
That would be the worst case scenario as a cancer growing at that spot.
Let's not go to that pathway too quickly though, so what are some other options that could be going, it could be just scar tissue, that's possibility.
It could be your body healing that with a virus tissue lay down, that could be the possibility.
So, there's lots of different possibilities there.
You could, what could you do to prevent it? Well, we don't know what the cause of that is.
It's, I would certainly be ready, you're right, I think that's your big, that's your best bet for this to, to assume, you know, the worst maybe so that you are going to treat them at the worst.
If it's just scar tissue, it's just your body healing, there's nothing you need to do, no concerns whatsoever.
If there is some cancer cell growth, which remember, you were never without cancer, so you're always treated as if anyhow.
So, make sure you're running the right, put the bomb right over that for a while and you could tolerate it if it's not right in your eyes, try that.
So, you're just getting just some real direct hits of those frequencies on that, those are the kind of things I was going to do.